I think that commute ah and there's a
time when I was you know bullied and I
was tormented it was an emotional night
on Tuesdays Dancing with the Stars
honoring the pros and their hometowns
Derek Hough and bindi Irwin paid tribute
to Derek's childhood in Utah backstage
bindi got candid about handling pressure
praising Derek as much more than just a
dance partner just because of the love
and support from my family and from
Derek for just being the most amazing
teammate I mean this is all about that
that teamwork and not only do I have a
friend but he feels like an older
brother and it's just working together
yeah yeah Mark Ballas tributed his
parents during his rumba with Alexa Pena
Vega Alexa and I are gonna be dancing to
somewhere in time it's one of the last
songs that my parents danced together
like as a married couple
I get checked out Laura I know it has a
lot of meaning to him so I just want to
bring everything I have
Nick Carter's partner Shauna Burgess
opened up about her family's health
struggles my mom has been able to come
to LA to see me on Dancing with the
Stars unfortunately my dad and mine
can't they they're both on dialysis with
kidney failure and I wish so much that
they could just be here
[Music]
the night ended with the highest-scoring
couple Val and tamar braxton honoring
his parents who moved to New York City
for a better life my parents dropped
everything in Ukraine their job their
friends and came to New York City with
nothing just so that their kids could
become something everything I have right
now is because of them what crying stop
Wow
[Applause]